[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
t'avais jamais vu en vrai bonjour C'est
vrai
partie des gens qui souriait tout le
temps qui était
ensemble
alors un petit manitore cap sur vous et
puis en fait on va parler d'autre votre
attention il y a pas d'autre
[Musique]
il s'est révélé aux yeux des Français en
2008 dans Un dîner presque parfait
l'émission culte de M6 dans laquelle
Grégory Cuilleron a instantanément
séduit le public ces deux-là étaient
vraiment destinée à se rencontrer après
cela la sixième chaîne de Bata le lâcher
d'une semaine il participera coup sur
coup à plusieurs émissions de cuisine
dont la première saison de Top chef
après être devenu chroniqueur dans miam
l'émission de Cyril Lignac Grégory
poursuit son audit ses télévisuel en
présentant la tournée des popotes sur
France 5 une émission dans laquelle le
cuisinier nous a fait voyager dans le
monde entier c'est ça
aujourd'hui à la tête de son propre
restaurant à Lyon ce chef passionné et
engagé est devenu l'un des visages de la
cuisine en France ce n'est plus de
hasard Grégory cuir ou est notre invité
alors
on va
on va remplir votre attention mais avant
la pub j'ai qu'une question à vous poser
très honnêtement est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'on est assez de personnes j'allais
dire handicapé le mot on va dire le mot
on a droit est-ce qu'il y a cette
personne handicapées à télévision alors
je retourne un peu la question c'est à
dire que l'idée c'est est-ce que à
compétence égale on met suffisamment de
personnes handicapées c'est ça c'est un
truc faut pas que ce soit un frein mais
mettre des handicapés parce qu'ils sont
handicapés c'est pas leur rendre service
c'est faut mettre la compétence en avant
tout d'accord très si vous avez du
boulot je suis toujours preneur
vous êtes un resto si j'ai un autre
chose j'ai pas que le resto eh t'as les
dents longues toi
vous voulez vous voulez faire la télé
comme Cyril Lignac voilà exactement
RTL le matin et là j'ai les mêmes sistes
alors on va faire une tourte quand il
fait une tourte ah [ __ ] il est tout le
temps partout fais une pause Cyril
vous vous imaginez c'est lui disait de
leur moto par semaine dis donc
c'est pas des crêpes et une tour toutes
les 10 minutes fais Top Chef yes vous
étiez souriant ne voyez que vous cette
saison là et Dieu sait si moi ça me fait
chier les émissions en font une dinde et
tout ça mais vous mais vous j'ai envoyé
que vous vous dites souriant vous étiez
différents et vous avez fait cette
émission derrière restaurant ouais à
Lyon oui il y en a eu plusieurs là j'ai
celui que j'ai actuellement depuis 7 ans
à Lyon exactement je vais faire plein
d'autres choses mais quand on a un
restaurant on a si on n'est pas dedans
et cool alors je fais déjà plein
d'autres choses j'ai la chance de
pouvoir m'appuyer sur de bons associés
dans mon petit frère qui est qui est
sommelier et puis en fait il se trouve
que comme je suis beaucoup de trucs à
côté notamment la télé sur France 3
exactement je fais des conférences dans
les entreprises sur le sur l'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées la motivation enfin tout ça
et j'ai envie de pouvoir avoir toutes
ces cordes à mon arc du coup il faut
mettre un chef sur place et s'il y a un
chef sur place ou pas venir
l'enquiquiner sans arrêt donc je
participe à l'élaboration des recettes
je suis là régulièrement mais j'y suis
pas 24 c'est génial breaking new j'ai lu
ça c'est cet hiver pendant mes
conférences entourez-vous de gens qui
ont des projets de gens positifs l'être
humain est une éponge positif positif
pensez positive il suppose Namasté je
continue donc le restaurant c'est super
marié nous on coupe pas marié pourquoi
pas marier parce que ça c'est pas
présenté pour le moment mais pourquoi
pas oui oui des enfants pas les miens
pas du tout non
tout va bien PV bonne bagnole non je
rigole donc voilà donc
voilà très bien effectivement donc vous
gagnez tout ça et votre partage de fake
vraiment c'est que vous c'est il y avait
aucun tabou sur le handicap est-ce que
c'est M6 qui est venu vous chercher et
pardon mais on connaît les télés qui a
dit faut mettre un noir faut mettre un
[ __ ] il faut mettre un handicapé cette
année il en faut un est-ce que c'est ce
qui s'est passé et c'est ce que vous
avez ressenti est-ce que c'est comment
ça s'est passé à votre rêve sur M6 alors
je me suis posé la question bien
évidemment j'ai beaucoup aimé la manière
dont ils avaient traiter le truc parce
que justement il y avait pas il y avait
pas de focus là-dessus non ils sont pas
venus me chercher puisque je suis le
tout premier gagnant du tout premier
dîner presque parfait donc ça existe pas
à ce moment-là et je m'occupais de la
com d'un resto étoilé parce que je mets
bien la gastronomie quand même et ils
nous ont appelé pour savoir si parmi nos
clients avaient des gens susceptibles
d'être intéressés je dis les clients je
savais pas mais que moi ça m'intéressait
ils m'ont casté j'ai gagné ce truc là
bon après ça fait une notoriété de deux
jours dans le journal local et je me
suis retrouvé un an plus tard dans le
combat des régions donc était le truc
patio que j'ai gagné les gens pensent
souvent que j'ai gagné Top Chef parce
que j'ai gagné ce truc là avant
je vous le dis et du coup après ils
m'ont dit est-ce que tu veux pas faire
Top Chef une chronique avec Cyril Lignac
en face ça a changé véritablement ma vie
c'était il y a il y a plus de 13 ans il
y a plus de 13 ans et est-ce qu'à un
moment donné on vous a demandé de cacher
votre handicap ou jamais ah non non bien
sûr que non alors déjà
c'est vrai ouais non non pas du tout
alors j'ai eu des réflexions suite à Top
Chef on disait que c'est ça foutait la
gerbe de me voir cuisiner avec mon
moignon c'est une blague
j'ai foutu les boules sur le enfin
ouais ouais bien sûr les gens tu mets
l'air quand ils sont un peu masqués ils
disent un peu tout et n'importe quoi sur
le coup ça m'a un peu enquiquiné après
je me suis dit que c'était des bonnes
bonnes abruti quoi voilà tout alors je
vais vous dire un truc 2013 2023 ça veut
dire un truc les réseaux sociaux les
gens dans la rue quand tu es venu nous
voir forcément si vous n'aimes pas ils
viennent pas vous voir ici viennent
c'est qu'ils vous aime bien les réseaux
sociaux j'ai commencé à être heureux
quand j'ai arrêté de les lire ouais
c'est ça voilà donc arrêtez tout ça on
touche une sorte vous me le citez c'est
donc que ça vous avez marqué quand même
quand même à l'époque donc vous faites
effectivement maintenant beaucoup de
réunions tout ça pour l'insertion des
des handicapés c'est que vous faites des
conférences un peu partout ouais tout à
fait en fait j'ai été pendant 8 ans à
baisser de la gfip qui l'association de
gestion du fond d'insertion
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées j'étais contacté suite à mes
seconde parce qu'il faut savoir que dans
une entreprise normalement on est obligé
de devoir engager une personne
handicapée sinon on paye une amende
alors la plupart des personnes il faut 6
% de travailler en situation d'handicap
dans une entreprise de plus de 20
salariés et sinon on paye l'amende ouais
mais alors ça change franchement ça
change vachement je trouve les
mentalités sont il y a encore du boulot
mais les montagnes en véritablement
changé et puis maintenant on recrute
plus une personne parce qu'elle est
handicapée mais on recrute une personne
que j'expliquais tout à l'heure pour ses
compétences il se trouve qu'elle est
handicapées c'est quoi votre spécialité
aujourd'hui la cuisine bien sûr mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie
c'est un peu tout ça c'est à dire créer
des recettes votre rêve c'est une étoile
pas du tout
du tout du tout non non c'est trop de
contraintes c'est pas c'est pas alors là
des fois
c'est pas mon moteur moi je pense que
physiologie du coup elles sont perd elle
s'opère pendant la l'enfance et que de
ce fait tout ce qui nous procure des
émotions sont les plaques qui nous
rappellent les plats de notre enfance
donc moi ça me va bien comme genre de
truc alors je te laisse une question à
deux mais tu sais quoi
extrêmement taliste je lis un petit peu
entre vous je lis dans vos yeux je vois
que aujourd'hui vous me dites si je me
trompe votre restaurant ça vous amuse et
vous en avez un petit peu le tour France
3 c'est un peu chiant ça vous ennuie
vous avez envie en 2023 d'un nouveau
challenge c'est vrai ou pas ouais j'aime
bien les challenges je le vois dans vos
yeux j'essaie de trouver des challenges
après j'aime beaucoup par ailleurs le
restaurant et France 3
mais le restaurant à François c'est bon
qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez faire alors
il y a un truc qui me tient à cœur vas-y
ce serait de monter une boîte pour faire
travailler des personnes handicapées je
suis sur un projet comme ça autour de la
restauration et tout ça et pardon vous
savez qu'il y a un restaurant à Paris
les cafés joyeux les trucs joyeux
très 2021 qui vous servent donc il y en
a un quiz comme ça ça serait une sorte
de ce serait pas un resto ça serait pas
resté
dans le noir
moi j'ai une question cache j'adore
faire la cuisine et je sais pas si les
gens qui sont là aiment faire la cuisine
j'imagine elle se pose la question
cuisinier c'est le métier et je te pose
la question du monde ou tu as le plus
besoin d'utiliser une photo sa cuisine
tous les jours dès demain et en fait je
sais que tu as ce handicap de naissance
est-ce que il y a un moment on te voit
travailler quand tu fais des recettes
etc d'ailleurs d'avoir une espèce de
dextérité naturelle c'est un peu con
parce que ça me paraît évident c'est
trop handicap mais tu vis avec et est-ce
que ça t'empêche pas de faire des choses
ça paraît tout bête et quand tu dois
couper un concombre très rapidement
comme les cuisiniers on doit faire des
trucs très particuliers
j'ai une personne dans ma famille tu la
vérité qui a eu une aphasie donc il y a
tout à côté paralysé et on se rend pas
compte donc il y a pas de bras on se
rend pas compte elle est vie seul je
vous dis des trucs tout bête mais quand
tu es seul et que tu as qu'une main
ouvre un pot de cornichon ouvre un pot
de moutarde bien sûr ouvrez un truc
alors je la vois faire tu bloques
derrière souvent et je te tiens comment
on fait bah on est déjà je pense que
l'homme est malléable est arrivé à
s'adapter moi il y a un autre truc aussi
c'est que je n'ai pas qu'une main j'ai
une main plus un coup d'ailleurs ça le
moyen ça va être vachement vous avez
carrément ça ça joue vachement et puis
comme je suis né ainsi je me suis
construit je me suis construit comme ça
j'ai une finitude j'ai appris comme ça
il a pas fallu réapprendre on m'aurait
coupé le bras en plein milieu de ma vie
très intelligente que j'ai fait beaucoup
de psychologie pendant ses vacances mais
avant ça il y aura une question qui sera
moins Déborah non non je me demandais
parce qu'avec tous les moi j'ai pendant
très longtemps j'ai travaillé sur TPMP
ouvert à tous avec les personnes en
situation d'handicap et il y en avait
qu'il y avait des prothèses qui étaient
enfin plus que
réaliste quoi on croirait vraiment que
c'est des c'est des vraimentbres et
est-ce que ça ça pourrait pas vous aider
par exemple pour d'autres tâches ou
alors ça pourrait peut-être moi j'en
veux pas j'en ai alors j'en ai pour
faire du sport ça ça a changé ma vie
parce que je commence à avoir mal au dos
pour faire du vélo au lieu d'être comme
ça je suis bien droit faire des pompes
pour courir pour faire des photos voilà
c'est c'est cool
j'en ai fait quand j'étais jeune du
volume mais sans problème et tout en
fait moi mon but c'est de pouvoir
cuisiner dans n'importe quelle situation
sans avoir besoin de quoi que ce soit je
parle pour retrouver sans prothèse et
dire bah je suis incapable de cuisiner
la question pour vous mais déjà pardon
la banane de l'amitié tout le monde
[Applaudissements]
et je la tiens un peu parce que c'est un
faut que je mange beaucoup pour le sport
et j'en offre pas énormément je précise
autant je pense que vous dégagez quelque
chose moi dans ma société je m'entourer
de gens comme vous vous faites partie de
ces gens quand on déjeune avec quand on
dîne avec quand on les voit moi on
repart du dîner ou des déjeuner on est
boosté et on se dit qu'on peut tout
faire il y a des gens qui sont négatifs
et je vous jure ça s'appelle parfois des
coachs de vie et vous faites partie de
ces gens-là quand on vous voit on se dit
mais je vais y aller moi c'est je veux
j'ai une dernière question je vous
promets qu'on passe au dos du jour ma
dernière question on avait oui c'est
vrai qu'il est beau
et puis le nombre de personnes qui ont
trouvé leur sexualité après 40 ans
est-ce que j'ai une question pour vous
on avait demandé à une personne pardon
je sais plus son nom c'est un homme qui
n'a plus de bras plus de gens mais qui a
traversé
avec une petite fée on vous avait dit
bah en fait tu renais mais totalement
normalement avec tes jambes et tes bras
moi je garde ma vie elle a fait ce que
je veux je garde mon handicap je vous
pose la question si vous aviez eu
l'occasion de retrouver votre deuxième
bras sans avoir cette vie là vous
renoncez avec deux bras vous la prenez
non je pense que le handicap est une
chance et je n'aurais pas ce caractère
là j'aurais pas eu cette vie là si
j'avais pas solitude donc non puis comme
j'ai jamais connu là vous savez quoi
avec une [ __ ] je suis amoureux
[Applaudissements]